I was ten years old
when I learned what the word genocide
meant it was 2003 and my people were
being brutally attacked because of their
race hundreds of thousands murdered
millions displaced a nation torn apart
at the hands of its own government
my mother and father immediately began
speaking out against the crisis I didn't
really understand it except for the fact
that it was destroying my parents one
day I walked in on my mother crying and
I asked her why we were burying so many
people I don't remember the words that
she chose to describe genocide to her
ten-year-old daughter but I remember the
feeling we felt completely alone as if
no one could hear us as if we were
essentially invisible this is when I
wrote my first poem about Darfur I wrote
poetry to convince people to hear and
see us and that's how I learned the
thing that changed me it's easy to be
seen I mean look at me I'm a young
African woman with a scarf around my
head and American accent on my tongue
and a story that makes even the most
brutal of Monday morning seem inviting
but it's hard to convince people that
they deserve to be seen I learned this
in my high school classroom one day when
my teacher asked me to give a
presentation about Darfur I was setting
up the projector when a classmate of
mine said why do you have to talk about
this can't you think about us and how
it'll make us feel my fourteen year old
self didn't know what to say to her or
how to explain the pain that I felt in
that moment and in every moment that we
were forced not to talk about this her
words took me back to the days and
nights on the ground in Darfur where we
were forced to remain silent
where we didn't speak over morning tea
because the warplanes overhead with
any and all noise back to the days we
were told not only that we don't deserve
to be heard but that we do not have a
right to exist and this is where the
magic happened in that classroom when
all the students started taking their
seats and I began to speak
despite this renewed feeling that I
didn't deserve to be there that I didn't
belong there or have a right to break
the silence as I talked and my
classmates listened a CRM away my mind
it became calm and I felt safe it was
the sound of our grieving the feel of
their arms around me the study walls
that held us together I felt nothing
like a vacuum
I choose poetry because it's so visceral
when someone is standing in front of you
mind body and soul saying witness me
it's impossible not to become keenly
aware of your own humanity this changed
everything for me
it gave me courage every day I
experienced the power of witness and
because of that I am whole and so now I
ask will you witness me they hand me the
microphone as my shoulders sink under
the weight of this stress
the woman says the one millionth refugee
just left South Sudan can you comment I
feel my feet rocked back and forth on
the heels my mother bought banging the
question do we stay or is it safer to
choose flight my mind echoes the numbers
1 million gone 2 million displaced
400,000 dead in Darfur and the slump
takes over my throat as if each of those
bodies just found a grave right here in
my esophagus are one's country or north
and south and east and west so restless
the Nile couldn't hold us together and
you asked me to summarise they talked
about the numbers as if this isn't still
happening as if 500,000 didn't just die
in Syria as if 3,000 aren't still making
their final stand at the bottom of the
Mediterranean
as if there aren't entire volumes full
of fact sheets about our genocides and
now they want me to write one fact we
never talked over breakfast because the
warplanes would swallow our voices fact
my grandfather didn't want to leave home
so he died in a war zone fact a burning
bush without God is just a fire I
measure the distance between what I know
and what it's safe to say on a
microphone do I talk about sorrow
displacement I mentioned the violence
how it's never as simple as what you see
on TV how there are weeks worth of fear
before the camera is on do I tell her
about our bodies how they are 60% water
but we still burn like driftwood making
fuel of our sacrifice so I tell her the
men died first mothers forced to watch
the slaughter that they came for our
children scattering them across the
continent until our homes sank that even
castles sink at the bite of the bomb I
talked about the elderly our heroes too
weak to run too expensive to shoot how
they would March them hands raised
rifles at their backs into the fire how
their walking sticks kept the flames
alive it feels too harsh for a bundle of
wires and an audience to swallow too
relentless like the valley that filled
with the putrid smoke of our deaths
is it better inverse can a stanza become
a burial shroud well it stingless if I
say it softly if you don't see me cry
will you listen better well the pain
leave when the microphone does why does
every word feel as if I'm saying my last
30 seconds for the soundbite and now
three minutes for the poem my tongue
goes dry the same way we died becoming
ash having never been cold I feel my
left leg go numb and I realized that it
locked my knees bracing for impact I
never wear shoes I can't run in
thank you so I wanted to leave on a
positive note because that's the paradox
that this life has been and the places
where I learned to cry the most I also
learned how to smile after and so here
goes you have a big imagination or four
hundred thousand ways to cry for zeyneb
I am a sad girl but my face makes other
plans focusing energy on this smile so
as not to waste it on pain
the first thing they took was my sleep
eyes heavy but wide open thinking maybe
I missed something
maybe the cavalry is still coming they
didn't come so I bought bigger pillows
my grandmother could cure anything by
talking the life out of it and she said
that I could make a thief in a silo
laugh in the middle of our raging war
war makes a broken marriage bed out of
sorrow you want nothing more than to
disappear but your heart can't salvage
enough remnants to leave but joy joy is
the armor we carried across the borders
of our broken hamlet a hasty mix of
stories and faces that last long after
the flavor is gone a muscle memory that
overcomes even the most bitter of times
my memory is spotted with days of
laughing until I cried or crying until I
laughed laughter and tears are both
involuntary human reactions Testaments
to our capacity for expression so allow
me to express but if I make you laugh
it's usually on purpose and if I make
you cry I'll still think you are
beautiful this is for my cousins
bedridden on a random afternoon I hadn't
seen her since the last time we were in
Sudan together and there I was at her
hospital bedside in a 400 year old
building and France
zeyneb wanted to hear poems suddenly
English Arabic and French were not
enough every word I knew became empty
noise and Zeinab said well get on with
it and I read her everything that I
could and we laughed and we loved it and
it was the most important stage that
I've ever stood on surrounded by family
by remnants of a people who were given
as a dowry to a relentless war but still
managed to make pearls of this life by
the ones who taught me to not only laugh
but to live in the face of death who
place their hands across the sky
measuring the distance to the sign and
saying smile I'm gonna meet you there
and for zeyneb they never who taught me
love in a place like France
zeyneb who wanted to hear poems on her
deathbed I elated fibro myalgia her
heart muscles expanded until they
couldn't function and she held me and
she made me feel like gold and I said
Zeinab isn't it strange that your only
problem is that your heart was too big
thank you
[Applause]